[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
hit me with the birth name uh because i
read this and i was i can't even say it
my name yeah yeah yeah theodore capitani
von kurnitowski
so
crazy they used to call me the n word
all the time in louisiana which word is
that huh
i mean you can pick one but
it's uh this [ __ ] hey look at this a
drooling
this guy it's a gut it's like a it's saw
five it looks like a goddamn horror film
that's terrifying man
and the burger yeah it's known that the
burger they paint the stripes on it it's
not even at least just say hey
they paint the stripes on that
yeah dude they don't [ __ ] cook that
what grill do you see in a [ __ ]
burger king dude it's two sisters in the
back [ __ ] about the fists
like my mother's peruvian so like i feel
like i have a foreign mom right right
your dad's nicaraguan but he came in it
was 12. right seemed like an american
guy or no he seemed like he always
talked in spanish but nobody knew
spanish really by us so he would you
know people thought i think he was
insane or something we thought he was an
n word yeah a lot of times you're like
oh look at this guy with the [ __ ] you
know with the [ __ ] fan you know yeah
yeah with the [ __ ] fancy lisp
right yeah like man we can't understand
anything just guys
people thought he'd been electrocuted
the hotel or the motel where the door
opens just into the you know i mean to
the parking lot like this doesn't feel
good
um i stayed in a hotel a motel
in oakland once where uh horrible idea
man they're out of the gate man there
was like there were screams going on and
just everything was just you got like i
feel so unsafe that's ramadan i think
you just labeled basically every ramadan
every ramada and then i remember i went
to the counter i'm like what goes on
here
what goes on here i asked the lady at
the front test she goes i don't know
i was like i gotta get out of here she
was like yeah probably yeah probably so
yeah i work here but you should leave
one night i i i it was like when i was
still trying to save a ton of money and
i would i went to a days inn
in knoxville
um
and i said look can i just pay you a
couple of hours to sleep on this the
floor of a room right
and the lady's like yeah that's fine you
know but my boyfriend's gonna have to
sit in there while you sleep it was so
crazy and he did yeah and i paid him
like 40 bucks and slept in there for
like three hours he just looked at you i
don't know what he did i hope he dozed
off you know i like to hope that he
dozed off yeah you know i saw some
pictures of myself and i never had long
hair in any of them and i was like man
i'm going to be you know probably dead
at some point so i want to see what i
look like with long hair
and so i was like i'll grow long hair
out of my own head and so next thing you
know i started growing it out and it's
easier than you think you know
yeah
it is easier yeah it is easier like i
see these guys you think they're farmers
or something it's just somebody growing
their own hair yeah yeah the whopper
always looks like it [ __ ] got in a
domestic dispute
yeah
it does it does do you guys sleep in the
same bed or not what what
is this real yeah why would you think
that's real yeah what
we've been married for a million years
yeah
15 years yeah
yeah that's why i would ask probably oh
my god yeah yeah of course that's crazy
wait you don't plan on that
i don't know
are you seeing somebody now are you
serious no not serious i mean i'm dating
but not serious yeah do you want to get
married one day i don't know i bet i
don't know if i can sleep in the same
bed i don't know if i could sleep in the
same house but i do envision like wait a
minute why yeah
like houses that have like a sidewalk
that's really close so they
sponsored us took money away
and then came back and then made uh
christina also like a paid endorser so
yeah that's cool yeah it's very cool so
yeah we're definitely hardcore
mcdonald's family now yeah and why they
take it away they take it away because
um the first episode that they promoted
we had this guy put a butt plug in
his a video where he and he had a ruined
orgasm so he came
when he didn't want to because he had a
butt plug in and he was [ __ ] a [ __ ]
sleeve and so he was like trying it out
and he was like oh the [ __ ] sounds like
a real outdoorsman theo do you laugh at
violence no i do not act this is
interesting
maybe you're a normal human being i am
yeah
this is not what your husband does oh
well we'll cue those out look at him
jesus he's a psychopath how many
seven-year-olds are trapped inside of
that man
no
oh my god
you're like a slave [ __ ] for young
seven-year-olds
oh my god this right here you know we
get we have the the the great benefit of
having so many people send in clips and
videos and this is somebody's in their
car and there's an explosion like at a
plant and this is just a clip of
of them noticing it i guess
bro what the [ __ ] i can feel the [ __ ] i
know bro i can feel that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on my god
my [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] just happened
so well it's good to know that every
everybody can use the n-word again
that's one thing that's good to know now
to be fair if you're listening that is a
massive ball of fire we're not talking
about that's some [ __ ] 200 feet up in
the air yeah it looks like a damn uh
[ __ ] hydrogen bomb went off oh that's
that real [ __ ] right that's a real [ __ ]
get rid of your first wife right there
[ __ ] look at that [ __ ] man
that's crazy wow that's crazy
yeah i'm almost i wonder how close you
have to get to light a cigarette on it
you think probably not that right there
dude yeah
i don't say the n-word but i do
but i sound as dumb as them well you're
like dude
these are also children also these guys
are probably 16. yeah
it's our lives but yeah
but what's the reaction
i'd drive into and get that class action
check
that's my [ __ ] dude
we used to be in the class i grew up in
that class action building did you ever
were you ever a part of a class action
oh yeah i've been really
well there was that one against elijah
schlesinger did you guys get that one in
the mail i even got that one what there
was someone with her and ticketmaster or
something that happened really my gosh
no there's a class action suit
like there is and i could be miss
phrasing or something but yeah it's not
it's public knowledge i'm sure i got
what in the you know you get those
random ones like the hair dryers are
killing people
at the end of it i'll put some [ __ ] like
that
really clearing their throat a lot yeah
you know in public or you're like come
on man
you're like dude what the [ __ ] are you
doing like
guys doing
with their teeth
oh yeah i was in a steam room you know
this guy was like
i was like you get it
did you get it dude i was in a
self-esteem room it was a bunch of
people just trying to feel better yeah
oh it could have been kurt schlesinger
maybe then oh that's a different person
yeah it could have been cursed sorry
eliza oh he had those faulty ironing
boards yeah
this is a god a yiddish fella with some
[ __ ] shady ironing boards
not eliza schlesinger not eliza oh my
god well whatever boy i got that money
son you got that money yeah holy [ __ ] so
i got about i think thirty dollars out
of that so you signed up that's cool
yeah i like to just be involved in the
community yeah i like that
your ass is kind of like the last kind
of staycation i feel like like i don't
like to kind of yeah
i think if you're putting stuff in your
butt and you're not running across a
border dude then you're [ __ ] yeah
you're wasting time that's what i say
it's really i don't know man
you put things in your ass
no when i was young i didn't like when i
learned about that i had an [ __ ] yeah
but not as an adult no
no
this thing this thing that he puts in
does not seem like jv squad [ __ ] oh wow
advanced
really advanced and mcdonald's was not
cool with it oh yeah it's like hiding a
[ __ ] crab leg in your sweater you
know
there's a cleaning lady that comes to my
apartment and so she was there and so
that's always a little bit like you have
to work around her yeah it's annoying a
little she breaks a lot she breaks a lot
of stuff yeah
and it's like i just have to be
understanding yeah that's hard so i had
to take a you know i had to be
understanding she broke some glass and
she broke something else
so you're like i'll break your [ __ ]
jaw if you do well there's a voice in my
head there's an angry jiminy cricket
beating a [ __ ] craw a crowbar into
his hand that wants to say that yeah
yeah what else did she break you said
she broke something else she's broke
some other stuff she broke the microwave
she's broken the um
the coffee thing she's broken oh she's
broken a lot of stuff
my legs fell asleep in an uber the other
day and i had to get out this blanker
was driving and she was pissed that i
wouldn't get out
and i'm like how did your legs fall
asleep i have bad circulation really in
my legs yeah in my arms i can do almost
anything
but so it's like the next thing you know
it's like i gotta get out right and
she's like i already accepted another
passenger you know and it's like
my legs are asleep yeah yeah and she's
like you're the first human being that's
ever said this to me no i literally
she's like if she she goes if you knew
you were going to be handicapped you
should've brought a a wheelchair and i'm
like this is it's almost at that point
unsafer to be in with this girl what did
i do
[ __ ] got out
just jumped out like hands first like a
[ __ ] and then pulled yourself up yeah
like i mean yes scooted you scooted like
i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then how
long did you say on the sidewalk with
your on probably two minutes actually
probably a little longer because i got
on my phone okay and uh i didn't even
realize that my legs are kind of woken
back up but this is a frequent thing
that happens
i would say it happens to me if i'm
doing like a stool or something going
number two or if i am but that's where
it's common but you're also just sitting
in a car yeah but this lady i think the
seat was um i would say it was
aftermarket
so if i can head hey
yeah it just cut off the circulation it
could have been part of her move you
never know okay i'm out there it's on
it's an unlit area you know a couple of
[ __ ] you know papa's pop out the
trunk and get you you know not a bad
move really yeah you got the crossbar
within the seat that cuts off people's
circulation they get out can't walk
right two guys get them
standard
yeah pretty standard yeah that's called
the cincinnati [ __ ] shuffle
i got here and i was just kind of
frustrated i had this bag of stuff you
know and it's in like a garbage bag i
saw that yeah so
you know
and so it's just like different things
in there and then
i got i was in the parking lot i didn't
know where to go the numbers are very
yeah it's a confusing number system it's
it's not it's not laid out very well
prior to that for sure and a lot of
times numbers you know
they go i mean numbers know what they're
doing they're organized and we in this
[ __ ] they [ __ ] try to redo it here
yeah then so i'm out there yeah i'm
standing by this post office box i got
my bag of stuff
and then this couple rolls up and
they're smoking and they're trying to
mail something in one of these mail
slots you know
and the lady gets out of the car and
she's like who are you with that's what
she said right to you yeah and i was
like and i was already kind of [ __ ]
pissed dude and now i'm like having to
like
you know like rep my set out here with
these [ __ ] you know by the mail
thing
so [ __ ] got a little bit weird and then
her husband kind of said something or
whatever he did
yeah bro right out here said something
to you yeah and that's why i was like
well where is anybody does anybody care
you know i'm out here with a bag of
stuff in a garbage bag and you felt
abandoned yes i felt a man and this
lady's out there the guy's honking the
horn then to get his wife back in the
car and she had pulled too close to the
mail thing yeah to get her door open and
she was trying to get out but also
trying to smoke at the same time it's
important yeah
there was another club that these dudes
owned to get like friends mm-hmm and one
of the dudes
was a recovering addict
his main choice was crack and he had but
he had like a very addictive
hufflepuff boy i was [ __ ] sniffing
dory yeah yeah yeah he was he's
definitely hufflepuff and he was he was
addictive in every sense so he was like
you like the shirt there's like a blue
shirt i i got i got 12 of them yesterday
and i was like okay man so we like we we
had eaten somewhere across the street
and we were like oh they had this really
good uh dessert there and then he was
like the next day he was like i tried it
so good i bought 16 for everybody here i
was like you are out of your [ __ ]
mind
so then when it comes time to settle
he's like uh he has a great week we'd
sold out to shows he's like
can you guess what you're uh getting and
i was like i don't i don't guess i know
exactly what i'm getting he was like how
do you know i was like well we have a
deal
so since all the shows were sold out i
know the amount of tickets and i know
the ticket price and i know the
percentage
so then i know exactly what i'm getting
yeah he was like really i was like yeah
dude like
that's how this works he's like oh yeah
he goes we'll write down what you think
it is i go i don't think it's anything i
know exactly what it is
so
he's like well how much is it mark
summers who's the guy who's caught up
there what are you talking about so he
gives me a pen and paper i write down
the exact amount i go it is exactly this
amount and i show it to him he's like
that's not what i have i'm like then you
made a mistake you're wrong and so he's
like i have this and i'm like nope so
then he's like i gotta call like sandra
i'm like okay so then sandra comes up
and she just like works
she's all coked up probably big blonde
teased hair he was like tom said
that he's supposed to get this
and i have this and she was like and i'm
like sandra listen there's nothing to
debate here
it is definitely this and then she looks
at me she's like
he's like i guess you're right
writes the chat i was like i'm never
coming back here again
that's like a venue where like i
immediately took that check i was like
drive me to a bank like right now
because this is not going to clear out
monday did you see that one
did you see that one of that girl
getting the bullseye tattooed on her
[ __ ] just like a couple days ago oh
man have you seen that one can you pull
it up it's really special and where was
it in vietnam no
no the [ __ ] the tattooer is wearing a
surgeon's mask oh my god dude
this is why i don't want to fly abroad
to get my teeth whitened or anything
you might not see water
to bathing for days you know 100 degrees
out and you're wearing tight [ __ ]
oh like my like a french [ __ ] you're
in a palace i mean it's just like tight
velvet [ __ ] yeah because and it also
took like an hour to someone help you
get dressed you're not taking that off
no not for a while man you're sleeping
in that you're getting up you'll wash
your face
you just i mean
your dookie shoot had to stay everything
everything was raw dude i bet they let
dogs eat clean their ass out i bet yeah
remember that crotch or the crotch froth
on like imagine a hot day oh like sam
adams down there it's gonna be nasty
yeah man like bulkhead oh yeah yeah like
your [ __ ] dick is pouring a uh with
someone with the big head on it
the guinness guinness yeah yeah like
your dick's pouring against you your
dick's point again isn't
from a block away oh people would be
like who's that
that's kevin man yeah
he's here yeah he just came from florida
yeah oh man imagine what it smell like
in florida dude imagine going to visit
somebody writing them letters and you'll
be there in a couple months you never
show up you [ __ ] killed yeah all the
time that had to happen
and you were just coming to hang out or
imagine if you're like i love someone oh
you're writing letters it takes two
months to get there but imagine i'll be
i bet love was so much intense yes yeah
but imagine if you're like all right i'm
gonna board this ship
i'm gonna set sail and then meanwhile
her letter is coming back like i met
somebody you [ __ ] show up that had to
happen all the time yeah somebody showed
up you're like it took me six months to
get here they're like
i met somebody yeah
the slowest stalker the slowest stock
dude i did uh reminds me i did a casino
one time and i felt like i defended
people on stage and they gave me a check
after but i was worried it was over the
weekend that they were going to like
cancel cancel it
so the whole weekend bro i ended up
staying at the casino an extra two days
and just doing nice stuff around the
building what kind of what city were you
or what area was somewhere in i think
michigan or something yeah or minnesota
just like
milling around is doing that i think you
guys offended them
yeah i just think that maybe i didn't do
the right amount of time i literally
haven't been on stage in like a month i
don't know what it happened so
and uh and i got up there i was like oh
i got this and i did not have it right
and it was rough and it was like their
banquet it was like their employee
banquet and it was like i just felt like
i ruined their whole yeah vibe so i i
stay i got to move my flight and stay
there an extra two days and just like
was nice around town and like it's
hilarious nice around the building
hugged people took pictures and just
shook hands and [ __ ]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]